[Musique]
on a l'impression d'être en guerre assez souvent
quand à Ferry Creek, comme si nous étions dans cette
guerre des bois,
je n'ai pas peur de ces gens et vous ne
devriez pas non plus,
ce sont les hommes de main du gouvernement
et puis vous  oublie comme pourquoi sommes-nous ici
comme quoi défendons-nous
les choses qui vivent
ici vivent ici depuis 2 000 ans
j'en pleure en fait
je suis ici parce que je veux me dresser
contre ces forces politiques qui ont
opprimé les peuples autochtones  et ont
pris leurs terres
notre histoire au canada est vraiment sombre
vous emmenant dans une forêt tropicale isolée où
les défenseurs des terres mettent leur corps
en ligne pour arrêter l'exploitation forestière de certaines
des dernières forêts anciennes de la
colombie britannique plus d'un millier d'arrestations
ont été  fait depuis le début
du mouvement il y a deux ans, ce qui en fait l'un
des plus importants de l'histoire canadienne
pour la brute Je rencontre
Cheyenne Gunville, une délinquante autochtone et
nous marcherons jusqu'aux lignes de front
où elle est  Je me bats depuis des mois et
j'ai été arrêté huit fois [Applaudissements] D'accord, d'accord, je me prépare à prendre la
tête, je t'aime, d'accord,
puis-je tomber,
euh, je serai de retour demain à un moment donné,
oui, je ne sais pas à quelle heure je  je t'aime
maman
tu es en sécurité là-haut je le ferai
je vais laisser partir le défenseur des terres maman
va sortir
je vais attraper mon sac et mon avant-bras
est venu et je pense que nous sommes prêts à partir d'
accord
je vais juste attraper mes cannes et  alors lancez
ce chien dedans ils vont charger
vous passez moi mes adolescents d'
accord d'
accord faisons
ce blocus de ferry creek est une position
contre jusqu'à jones
ils sont une grande société d'exploitation forestière
si vous pensez à essayer de protéger une
immense forêt que nous avons alors  créé tous
ces camps de protection autour de Fairy
Creek afin de garder l'industrie et l'
application de la loi hors d'ici,
je voulais juste aussi
vous montrer de quoi je parlais
plus tôt en
ce moment, nous avons toute une division de la GRC
qui est ici pour cibler les peuples autochtones
et ils  étiquetez-le sur le côté de leur
camion, vous k  maintenant donc pour
moi, j'entre dès que je vois que
je me sens ciblé et que je ne me sens
pas en sécurité, donc
je suis ici
pour me battre pour la terre, je suis ici parce que
je veux me dresser contre ces
forces coloniales qui ont opprimé
les peuples autochtones  et ont pris leurs
terres pendant des siècles, les choses qui se
passent en ce moment
partout en Colombie-Britannique partout au
Canada sont toujours la continuation
de ce à quoi mes ancêtres ont été confrontés, mais
ma mère et ma grand-mère, il n'y a pas si
longtemps, nous pensons que ces choses sont
si loin dans le passé, mais ils le sont, ils
ne le sont pas, ils sont ici et ils
nous hantent encore à ce jour
lorsque vous vous levez et que vous utilisez votre voix
contre ces
forces coloniales, ils essaient de vous faire taire
mes arrestations à Fairy Creek ont été vraim
nt  violent
[Musique]
j'ai reçu un coup de poing au visage
j'ai été jeté au sol par mes
tresses
et toutes mes arrestations ressemblent à ça
ils ne veulent pas que je sois là-bas pour
protéger ces terres et dire la
vérité et ainsi de suite  ils feront  tout ce qu'ils
peuvent pour me faire descendre,
nous sommes en route vers le pont du camp de la rivière
lambach, nous avons donc environ deux
heures de marche devant nous
à un moment donné
euh en cours de route, nous sommes probablement habitués
aux 20 camps
de protection de  hq tout le chemin jusqu'à la rivière donc nous
pourrons passer ceux le long du chemin aussi
aucun
[Rires]
vous savez que
ce n'est plus du camping d'été et donc
nous descendons vraiment à des nombres très bas
pour tout
comment vous sentez-vous
les jambes brûlent
en décembre il y a trois ans j'ai commencé à
me sentir vraiment mal je dirais dans les
six mois j'ai commencé à perdre ma capacité
à marcher
quatre mois plus tard je me suis réveillé et j'ai perdu
ma capacité à parler donc je ne pouvais pas parler
pendant 10  mois
j'ai été mal diagnostiqué sept fois cela dépend vraiment à
qui vous demandez mon dernier diagnostic
était quelque chose appelé
trouble neurologique fonctionnel
j'ai fait des traitements vraiment très intensifs
des
mois avant de venir à Fairy Creek
qui
m'a rendu vraiment malade sur le moment mais
à long terme  c'est que ça
m'a vraiment aidé,
vous savez, l'année dernière à cette époque, euh, j'avais
une
moyenne de 10 à 15 crises par jour
et des tremblements, donc mon corps allait
de tremblements en crises, de tremblements en
crises et je me souviens allongé dans mon  lit en
pensant que je ne sais pas comment je vais
continuer à vivre comme comment continuer
une fois arrivés au camp de la rivière, ce sera
ma plus grande randonnée que j'ai faite depuis plus de
trois ans et ce sera
vous savez quelque chose à célébrer  parce que
je ne voulais presque pas continuer à vivre l'année dernière
donc je ne savais pas comment
je pouvais continuer alors hourra je
vais défendre les terres de Fairy Creek
oh
oui
mec ouais on a juste été assassinés
mais où les avons-nous poussés attends merci
vous ne laissez pas ils viennent de partir
wow ouais alors nous allons reconstruire d'accord
ouais et ensuite je suis prêt à jeter
pour demain
[Musique]
de quelque façon que je puisse
m'enfermer dans quelque chose
ça va être une [ __ ] d'
averse torrentielle demain  mon dieu nouveaux visages
fraise
je le ferais  ça ne manque pas c'est ma maison pendant des
mois
c'est vraiment difficile d'être ici
parce que nous avons affaire à
une brutalité agressive avec la police
avec des bûcherons nous sommes dans tous les éléments à
Fairy Creek
que ce soit comme des averses torrentielles
il neige il grêle
nous vivons littéralement à l'extérieur
et nos camps sont constamment pris
[Applaudissements]
mais certaines personnes en ce moment qui sont dans des euh
loraxes et qui ont leurs bras dans un
appareil dans lequel euh ils vont mettre leurs bras
puis entrer nous disons  les gens
aiment assez souvent être prêts à être dans
ce dragon
pendant quelques jours comme vous pourriez être ici
entre une heure et deux jours en
ce moment mon bras est attaché au
sol
dans ce que nous appelons un dragon
et euh ouais je suis ici en train de bloquer  la route
pour
protéger la dernière des forêts anciennes
êtes-vous préoccupé par la police et bien je les
ai vus être vraiment violents
ici comme je l'ai vu faire beaucoup de
choses folles mais
je pense
qu'être ici est
plus important  que tout ce qu'ils pourraient
faites-le
si nous attendons plus longtemps, ces forêts
seront abattues et
si nous attendons plus longtemps dans le changement climatique,
vous savez qu'il sera trop tard pour revenir en arrière,
donc c'est tout et le gouvernement
n'intervient pas du tout et donc  vous
savez, à un certain moment, c'est assez
et nous devons faire les choses nous-mêmes,
c'est juste un bon rappel de venir dans
le vieux bosquet,
c'est un endroit vraiment spécial pour moi, j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps
ici en été et je pense aussi  que
cette forêt est la
raison pour laquelle mon corps a tellement guéri
cette zone est en fait une zone qu'ils
veulent vraiment enregistrer il y a de
très grands arbres ici et
c'est celui-ci l'un d'eux
vous savez je sais que
toutes les choses  qui vivent ici,
vous savez qu'elle a probablement près de
2000 ans et je sais par
des biologistes
qu'ils ont dit que vous savez qu'ils sont une fois
que ces arbres ont disparu que ces
écosystèmes sont éteints
[Applaudissements
] y a-t-il une présence policière
il y a  un camion assis à l'y d'
accord
d'accord
sont mes veines et c'est ce que je veux
la terre est mon corps la rivière est mon
sang
les arbres sont mon
c'est ce que je veux
nous restons ensemble
notre ami a besoin d'uriner et
j'essaie de les aider à uriner laissez-moi faire
non,
le ciblage qui se produit est
juste d'essayer d'aider mon ami à uriner
, puis de
m'appeler un instigateur quand je fais partie de
l'instigateur de cela
, puis assurez-vous de saisir mon sac et de
me saisir afin de retirer mon sac
mais nous  'essaye juste d'aider notre ami
qui nous protège
[Musique]
nous n'allons nulle part
donc nous continuons à tenir la ligne
euh
je dirais jusqu'à
probablement vers cinq ou six heures et
donc
euh et ça donc nous tellement  ce fut une
journée réussie
dans la mesure où nous avons empêché l'industrie
et l'application de la loi de se déplacer
partout où ils n'en ont pas fait, ils
n'ont pas pu faire d'extractions, alors un
petit groupe d'entre nous euh a décidé que nous
allions  préparez-vous à
redescendre la montagne et donc après la randonnée
probablement se  ven kilomètres à un
kilomètre de
um
camp en bordure de route et euh
j'étais euh mais je me sentais comme pris en embuscade par la
police
je me souviens juste que
mon nom a été crié puis
jeté dans le sol
ils arrêtent des fraises hé laissez-
moi arrêter de traîner ses
gars nous toujours  Je dois me serrer les coudes comme
s'ils me ciblaient juste
parce qu'ils sont racistes
quel est leur raisonnement pour dire pourquoi
ça se passe
[Musique]
tu es dégoûtant
dégoûtant
c'est difficile de ne pas être en colère et
frustré et de
ne pas vouloir faire rage à
cause de la couleur de mon  [ __ ] de peau,
nous exposons que le génocide de la
terre se produit toujours que le
génocide du peuple se
produit toujours que le père inégal de cette
terre est réduit
au silence par des accords de partage des revenus parce
qu'il a été opprimé et mis dans une
réserve avec  rien que j'aie tellement d'espoir
parce que je n'ai jamais
vu des gens rassembler leurs ressources
et entrer
et juste tous les jours comme si nous n'étions pas
payés pour être ici
nous d  nous n'avons pas toutes les ressources dont
ils disposent mais nous sommes toujours là et ils
ne nous ont toujours pas sortis et donc j'en
ai quelques-uns
j'ai un peu d'espoir vous savez
et je pense que c'est pourquoi je suis ici
parce que j'ai encore  espoir à
cause des gens
[Applaudissements]
vous